This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I just want to let you know before we get into this episode that we are going to be discussing some intense subject matter today to do with physical abuse, emotional abuse, verbal abuse, that sort of thing. So if that is something that you're particularly sensitive to or you don't really want to hear somebody talking about today, just
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《心理学与你的20多岁》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。在进入这一集之前，我想让你知道，我们今天将讨论一些关于身体虐待、情感虐待、言语虐待等方面的激烈主题。所以，如果你对这些内容特别敏感，或者你今天真的不想听到有人谈论这些，那么
giving you a heads up so you can skip this episode or maybe come back to it at a later time when you are feeling, you know, maybe in a more stable place. There will be some links to some resources and some assistance in the show description as well. Let's get into it. Today, we are talking about trauma bonds and no, not to people who bond through hardship because I hate to break it to you. That is actually not a trauma bond. We are talking about a powerful kind of connection that forms between two people when one person manipulates their own trauma or the trauma of the person that they are with to create a highly dependent, highly painful, highly manipulative relationship that is founded on the highs and lows of emotional gaslighting,
给你提个醒，这样你可以跳过这一集，或者在以后你感觉状态更稳定的时候再回来听。节目描述中也会有一些资源和援助的链接。让我们开始吧。今天，我们讨论的是创伤纽带，不，不是指那些通过苦难建立联系的人，因为我很抱歉告诉你，那实际上不是创伤纽带。我们谈论的是当一个人操纵自己的创伤或他们所处之人的创伤，从而建立一种高度依赖、高度痛苦、高度操纵的关系时，两人之间形成的一种强大的联系，这种关系建立在情感煤气灯效应的起伏之上，
maybe even emotional abuse, founded on hot and cold behavior, founded on betrature, founded on betrayal and hurt rather than love. What nobody tells you about trauma bonds is how often people who think they would never be susceptible to this kind of thing end up in these relationships all of the time because of how powerful inconsistency is at hijacking our brain's reward system. When somebody gives you the most perfect fantasy version of love one day and then switches it into the most terrible kind of love the next, that emotional whiplash does something dangerous to your brain. It teaches you that if you just hold out a little bit longer, the good version is
甚至可能是情感虐待，建立在忽冷忽热的行为之上，建立在背叛和伤害之上，而不是爱。关于创伤纽带，没人告诉你的是，那些认为自己永远不会受到这种事情影响的人，却因为不一致性在劫持我们大脑奖励系统方面的强大作用，而不断陷入这些关系中。当某人一天给你最完美的幻想版爱情，第二天又把它变成最糟糕的爱情时，那种情感上的鞭打会对你的大脑造成危险。它教会你，只要你再坚持一会儿，好的版本
going to come back around. And so it leaves you holding onto potential and holding on to these terrible relationships and these terrible people because of the potential of reward. And that way, you know, this person, the person that people form a trauma bond with becomes both their biggest source of unhappiness, but also the biggest source of happiness at times. Because this person is the one who can give and take those things, who can give and take safety. People who have never experienced this may look at it from the outside and think, I don't know, why don't you just leave? That person's obviously not good for you. Why don't you know you deserve better? Why don't you just walk away? But what they don't understand is
就会回来。所以它让你因为潜在的奖励而紧紧抓住潜力，抓住这些糟糕的关系和这些糟糕的人。这样，你知道，与人形成创伤纽带的这个人既成了他们最大的不幸来源，有时也是最大的幸福来源。因为这个人是能够给予和夺走这些东西的人，能够给予和夺走安全感的人。从未经历过这种情况的人可能会从外部看它，并想，我不知道，你为什么不直接离开？那个人显然对你不好。你为什么不知道你值得更好的？你为什么不直接走开？但他们不明白的是
the insanely powerful neurobiological, psychological, psychological, physical, emotionally addictive patterns that this kind of relationship creates, which essentially mean that our own self-preservation, our own instincts, our own emotions, our rationality, it all just gets so totally scrambled. I think what they don't realize is how smart abuses and partners can be, how well they understand the mechanisms of insecurity and psychology, and how well they can manipulate love. So this is exactly what we're going to be revealing and talking about today. If you have ever found yourself in this kind of trauma bond, if you are recovering and healing from a relationship that matches this pattern, or if you're just watching like a friend
这种关系所创造的极其强大的神经生物学、心理学、生理学、情感上瘾模式，这本质上意味着我们自己的自我保护、我们自己的本能、我们自己的情绪、我们的理性，一切都变得完全混乱了。我认为他们没有意识到虐待者和伴侣可以有多聪明，他们有多了解不安全感和心理学的机制，以及他们能多好地操纵爱。所以这正是我们今天要揭示和讨论的内容。如果你曾经发现自己处于这种创伤纽带中，如果你正在从一段符合这种模式的关系中恢复和治愈，或者如果你只是像一个朋友一样看着
or anybody in your life going through this and you're trying to understand like how you can help them, I think and I hope that this episode will bring you some clarity. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of trauma bonds. Let's start by really clarifying, because this is totally essential. We really need to clarify what we mean by a trauma bond because it has been used very, very casually these days, and that has definitely diluted its meaning considerably, not because of anybody's poor intentions, just because of concept creep. Concept creep is essentially the casual expansion of serious terms to mean,
你生活中的任何人经历这些，而你正试图理解你如何能帮助他们，我想我也希望这一集能给你带来一些清晰。所以事不宜迟，让我们进入创伤纽带的心理学。让我们从真正澄清开始，因为这绝对是必不可少的。我们真的需要澄清我们所说的创伤纽带是什么意思，因为它这些天被非常非常随意地使用，这绝对大大稀释了它的含义，不是因为任何人的恶意，只是因为概念蔓延。概念蔓延本质上是严肃术语的随意扩展，以表示
less and less serious things and therefore take away the important meaning of these words. I think we have all heard of people who have become friends at a terrible workplace you know, joke that they are trauma bonded or people who have dealt with like the same tragic, awful X will be like,
越来越不严肃的事情，从而剥夺了这些词的重要含义。我想我们都听说过在糟糕的工作场所成为朋友的人，你知道，开玩笑说他们是创伤纽带，或者处理过像同一个悲惨、糟糕的前任的人会说，
how'd you guys meet? Oh, we like, we have like a trauma bond. We're like trauma bonded. That is very different to the original meaning of this term. Trauma bonding was first advised in 1997 by this man called Dr. Patrick Kahn's, who, interestingly, also is known for his work actually on sex addiction as a sidebar, but he essentially created, discovered, founded this term to refer to a relationship between
你们是怎么认识的？哦，我们就像，我们有创伤纽带。我们就像创伤纽带。这与这个术语的原始含义非常不同。创伤纽带最初是由帕特里克·卡恩斯博士在1997年提出的，有趣的是，他作为旁注也以他在性成瘾方面的工作而闻名，但他本质上创造、发现、创立了这个术语，指的是一种关系，介于
an abuser and an abused person or a manipulative person and a target that is formed in a way that gets somebody to stay against their best interests because of trauma, because trauma creates a bond. In contrast to like the normal use of the word bond to describe like a deep, healthy reaction to love and emotional vulnerability and connection, trauma bonding refers to how we respond to emotional volatility and how we respond to control, sometimes, you know, actually tunneling further into the relationship that is creating these bad feelings for protection when it's obviously against our best interest because for some reason our brain isn't able to rationally respond in these situations. It has been scrambled by somebody
虐待者和被虐待者之间，或者操纵者和目标之间，这种关系以一种让某人违背自身利益而留下的方式形成，因为创伤，因为创伤创造了一种纽带。与“纽带”一词的正常用法（描述对爱、情感脆弱和联系的深层、健康的反应）形成对比，创伤纽带指的是我们如何对情感波动做出反应，以及我们如何对控制做出反应，有时，你知道，实际上为了保护而进一步钻进正在制造这些坏感觉的关系中，当这显然违背我们的最佳利益时，因为出于某种原因，我们的大脑无法在这些情况下理性地做出反应。它被别人的行为搞乱了。纽带，简单来说，真的只是一个连接。创伤纽带是一个通过邪恶的东西锻造出来的连接，但它毕竟是一个连接。简而言之，它是一种基于威胁和缓解循环的依恋，这使得处于这种关系中的人渴望认可。这种情况可以发生，是的，最常见于浪漫伴侣，但它也可以发生在父母、朋友、机构、导师身上，任何拥有情感控制权并能从关系中获取某人需要的东西并加以利用的人，这些都有可能变成创伤纽带。创伤纽带的开始通常是通过虐待者强烈的喜爱和赞美。爱情轰炸，比如重大的爱的宣言，
else's behavior. A bond is, you know, in simple terms, really just a connection. A trauma bond is a connection that is forged through something sinister, but it is a connection nonetheless. In short, it is an attachment based on cycles of threat and relief, which leave the person in this relationship desperate for approval. This can happen, yes, most often with a romantic partner, but it can also happen with a parent, it can happen with a friend, it can happen with an institution, a mentor, anybody who has emotional control and can take what somebody needs from a relationship and exploit it, these have the capacity to turn into trauma bonds. The way that a trauma bond begins is often through intense affection and praise from the abuser. Love bombing, like major declarations of love,
看起来像是激烈的奉献。这就像一种巨大的情感高潮。它超级强烈。被这样照顾是一种磁性的、令人上瘾的感觉。他们也可能，这一点至关重要，告诉那个他们打算与之形成创伤纽带的人关于他们自己创伤的故事，特别是来自童年、过去关系的创伤，以对另一个人产生深层的心理控制，但也为了博取同情。这个阶段是必不可少的。它基本上为这个虐待者提供了他们未来不良行为的情感不在场证明。
what appears to be fierce devotion. It's like a huge emotional high. It's super intense. It's like, it's a magnetic, addictive feeling to be cared for in such a way. They may also, and this is critical, tell the person that they are intending to form a trauma bond with stories of their own trauma, particularly from their childhood, particularly from past relationships, to generate like a deep psychological hold over this other person, but also to elicit sympathy. This stage is essential. It basically provides this abuse of this person with an emotional alibi for their future bad behavior.
他们需要这样做才能进行计划的下一部分，因为最终他们的行为会转变。他们会变得残忍。而拥有这个他们这样做的原因作为后盾，有助于他们向你推卸他们的行为。再说一次，就像我说的，最终它会升级。但问题是，这种升级通常也与温暖和喜爱随机并置。它会像，我爱你。你让我失望了，像没有人那样。我经历过的最伟大的事情，我再也不想见到你了。我觉得你很美。你让我恶心，这种反复无常。在他的文章《爱与斯德哥尔摩综合症：爱上虐待者的奥秘》中，这位心理学家，约瑟夫·卡弗博士，
And they need to do this in order to engage the next part of their plan because eventually their behavior is going to switch. They're going to become cruel. And having this reason why they do it to fall back on helps them dismiss their behavior to you. Again, like I said, eventually it's going to escalate. But the thing is, is that this escalation is often also randomly juxtaposed with warmth and affection. It will be like, I love you. You've disappointed me like nobody ever has. The greatest thing that's ever happened to me, I never want to see you again. I think you're beautiful. you disgust me, this flip-flop, flip-flop. In his article, Love and Stockholm Syndrome, the mystery of loving an abuser, this psychologist, Dr.
他称之为小善意感知。也许虐待者一直在对某人进行冷暴力，然后他们通过用礼物或拥抱打破冷暴力来向他们展示这种小善意。也许他们会排斥你、忽视你，然后突然转过身来想要你在身边。这就是那种缓解、痛苦和缓解的循环，缓解、痛苦、痛苦和缓解，就像不知道哪一个会到来。再说一次，他们成为恐惧的平等来源，也是安全的来源，这意味着即使某人想走开，他们所有的情绪调节，
Joseph Carver, he calls this small kindness perception. Perhaps the abuser has been giving somebody the silent treatment, and then they showed them this small kindness by breaking the silent treatment with a gift or a hug. Maybe they will exclude you, ignore you, and then suddenly turn around and want you around. this is that cycle of relief, pain and relief, relief, pain, pain, and relief, like not knowing which one's going to come. Again, they become an equal source of fear, but also of safety, meaning that even if somebody wants to walk away, all of their emotional regulation,
好的和坏的，都与另一个人捆绑在一起。有足够的快乐日子来诱惑你，也有足够的糟糕日子来困惑你。还有足够的借口让他们给你，让你认为他们可以改变。这种忽冷忽热的性格被描述为本质上像一个两面派的灵魂伴侣，我认为这是一个描述这种情况的绝妙术语。它基本上符合这种亲密和强化以及奖励和惩罚的模式。它符合这种模式，就像，这个人是一个身体里的两个不同的人。而这两个不同的人是如此难以解开，因为好的部分实在是太好了
good and bad, is tied up to this other person. There are enough good days to entice you and enough bad days to confuse you. and enough excuses that they're giving you to think that they can change. This hot and cold personality has been described essentially like a two-faced soulmate, which I think is like a brilliant term for describing this. It basically fits this pattern of intimate and reinforcement and reward and punishment. It fits this pattern of like, this person is two different people in one body. and these two different people are so difficult to disentangle because the good is just so good
而坏的部分与此截然不同，以至于字面上不可能知道什么是真实的，什么是虚假的。从那里开始，喜爱和残忍的循环继续，通常持续多年，对某些人来说甚至是一生，这说起来很悲惨，那么为什么它首先会发生呢？警告信号是什么？为什么这些情况会发生，为什么这么多人经常报告说就像它只是悄悄地靠近我？如果你没有经历过，我觉得很难理解。对创伤纽带原因的研究，这可能会让你感到惊讶，可能不会让你们中的一些人感到惊讶，实际上它实际上
and the bad is so different to that that it's literally impossible to know what's real and what's not. From there, the cycle of affection and cruelty continues, often for years, sometimes even for a lifetime for some people, which is tragic to say, so why does it happen in the first place? What are the warning signs? why do these situations occur and why do so many people often report being like it just kind of snuck up on me if you haven't lived it i feel like it's very hard to understand that research into the causes of trauma bonds this might surprise you might not surprise some of you actually it's actually
仍然处于非常早期的阶段，因为心理学家仍然在掌握，仍然在掌握所有这些的权力动态，但人们认为某人着手创造创伤纽带的核心原因之一，无论是故意的还是有点潜意识的，都是因为对权力和崇拜的深层需求。这高度归因于自恋人格特质或自恋型人格障碍。正如我们之前关于这个话题的一集所知，自恋者需要成为一切的中心，才能感觉自己很重要。无论他们是通过成功、金钱、赞美，还是通过浪漫操纵和扮演受害者来获得这一点，
still really in its early days and early stages because psychologists are still getting a grasp on just still getting a grasp on like the power dynamics of all of this but it is thought that one of the core reasons that somebody sets out to create a trauma bond, and whether that's deliberate or like a little bit subconscious, it is because of a deep need for power and adoration. This is highly attributed to narcissistic personality traits or a narcissistic personality disorder. A narcissist, as we know from one of our previous episodes on this, needs to be at the center of everything to feel like they matter. And whether they get that through success, through money, through praise, or through romantic manipulation and playing the victim,
就像，如果他们得到他们想要的，如果他们得到那个聚光灯，如果他们得到关注，如果他们得到崇拜，那基本上都是一样的。特别地，有一种自恋者被称为脆弱型自恋者。与这种人形成创伤纽带非常普遍。这种自恋者通过总是让自己成为受害者，通过确保他们的危机总是最大的危机，通过确保每个人都围绕着他们旋转，来占据房间和关系中的所有情感氧气。所以一个人是自恋的或具有高自恋特质是一个巨大的风险因素。另一个是如果这个人，或者任何一个人，有不安全的依恋风格。而这种风格是从过去的
like, it's kind of all the same if they get what they want, if they get that spotlight, if they get the attention, if they get adoration. In particular, there's a type of narcissist called a vulnerable narcissist. It's very prevalent to have a trauma bond with this kind of person. This is the type of narcissist who takes up all the emotional oxygen in the room and in a relationship by always making themselves the victim, by making sure that their crisis is always the biggest crisis, by making sure that everybody like orbits them. So one individual being narcissistic or being high and trait narcissism is a huge risk factor. Another is if the person who is, either person really, has an insecure attachment style. And one that is developed from past
纽带或过去的关系中发展出来的。我觉得我们都非常熟悉什么是不安全依恋风格，以及人们如何发展这种风格和关系。但再说一次，如果你对爱的唯一蓝图是喜爱是需要给予和夺走的东西，或者爱是需要赢得的，它不是自由给予的。那么质疑创伤纽带就变得更难，当新的浪漫伴侣做一些有点奇怪或有点邪恶的事情时，质疑就变得更难，因为你不知道替代方案。这就是爱。这就是你所知道的。这就是你父母彼此相爱的方式。这就是他们爱你的方式。所以所有这些对其他人来说是鲜红旗帜的警告信号，就像你只是错过了它们，因为你没有，
bonds or past relationships. I feel like we are all very familiar with what an insecure attachment style is and why, how people develop that style and relationships. But again, if your only blueprint for love is that affection is something to be given and taken away or that love needs to be earned, it is not freely given. It becomes harder to question a trauma bond and it becomes harder to question when a new romantic partner does things that are a little bit odd or a little bit nefarious because you don't know an alternative. That's what love is. That's what you know it as. That's how your parents loved each other. That's how they loved you. So all these warning signs that to other people would be these bright red flags, like you just miss them because you don't have,
你还没有学会不健康的爱与健康的爱是什么样子的。这其中也有一个生化元素，我不太常看到人们谈论它，但人类学家海伦·费舍尔，她实际上在她的研究中表明，这种爱实际上激活了一些与可卡因成瘾、酒精成瘾、赌博成瘾负责的大脑区域，因为我们刚才谈到的间歇性强化。基本上，有时你赢了，更多时候你输了，但有时你赢了。这感觉真的很好。这让你上瘾。这就像人们坐在老虎机前等待运气好转。我需要人们理解这一点。
you haven't learnt what unhealthy love versus healthy love looks like. There's also a biochemical element to this as well, which I don't see talked about very often, but the anthropologist Helen Fisher, she actually showed in her research that this kind of love actually activate some of the same brain regions that are responsible for cocaine addiction, alcohol addiction, gambling addiction, because of that intermittent reinforcement we were speaking about. Basically, sometimes you win, more often you lose, but sometimes you win. And that feels really nice. That keeps you hooked. That's Like people keep sitting at slot machines waiting for their luck to turn. I need people to understand this.
就像有一些强大的生物系统在这里对你不利，特别是在动荡的关系中。我认为所有这些化学物质的影响会深刻得多。你知道，你有，是的，多巴胺，但你也有催产素、加压素、血清素、皮质醇、去甲肾上腺素、肾上腺素，所有这些因为起伏太多而混合在一起。有太多的信号需要拦截，你的理性思维无法，我想，梳理清楚。所以你走开并理性地看待正在发生的事情的能力只是混乱了。当某人是你生活中最好和最坏部分的来源时，
Like there are some powerful biological systems working against your favor here, especially in a turbulent relationship. I think the effects of all these chemicals are going to be so much more profound. You know, you've got dopamine, yeah, but you've also got oxytocin, vasopressin, serotonin, cortisol, noraphyran, adrenaline, all mixing together because of how many highs and lows there are. there are just too many signals to intercept and for your rational mind to, I guess, sort through. So your ability to walk away and to rationally see what's happening is just scrambled. When somebody is the source of both the best and worst parts in your life,
你体内的任何化学物质都不是好或坏的化学物质。它只是对压力或环境中的事物做出反应，而你只是接收到了太多这些东西。特别地，就像多巴胺，我觉得它在很多方面都起作用，但特别是对于这个，关于多巴胺你可能不知道的一点是，是的，它给你快乐，但它也最小化痛苦，所以当你经历痛苦的情感体验时，对吧，多巴胺正在麻痹你，它正在减少你的疼痛反应，身体和情感上的，这样你就可以忍受困难的事情，但它也在这里给你这种奇怪的积极强化奖励，所以它对我们不利，对吧？多巴胺被释放是因为你正在经历的事情很困难，
no chemical in your body is a good or bad chemical. It just responds to stress or things in your environment and you're just receiving so much of that. In particular, like dopamine, I feel like it plays a role in so much, but especially for this, something that you might not know about dopamine is that yeah it gives you pleasure but it also minimizes pain so when you're going through painful emotional experiences right dopamine is numbing you it's reducing your pain response physical and emotional so that you can endure hard things but it's also giving you this like strangely positive reinforcement reward here so it's not working in our favor, right? Dopamine is being released because what you're going through is hard,
但随后你的大脑就像，哦，但随后我们感觉很好。所以这本质上就像是虐待者的完美化学助手，他们正在利用那种忽冷忽热的人格来发挥他们的情感优势，但也从生化角度发挥优势。而且它是，它困住了人们。最后，我认为这里的另一个大因素只是时间。虐待者等待的时间越长，但，但，它，它困住了人们。但是，在展示他们这一面之前，他们通过那些早期的脆弱性披露能够获得更多的同情，但也知道他们正在创造更多的沉没成本。某人越难走开，因为他们已经在关系中投入了太多的时间。你还会注意到，起初，善良和
but then also your brain's like, oh, but then we feel good. So this is essentially like the perfect chemical assistant to an abuser who is playing that hot and cold persona to their advantage emotionally, but also biochemically. And it is, it traps people. Finally, I think another big factor here is just time. The longer the person, the abuser waits, but, but, it's, it traps people. But, before showing the side of them, the more sympathy they are able to gain through those early on vulnerability disclosures, but also the more sunk costs they know they are creating. The harder it is for somebody to walk away because they've already invested so much time into the relationship. You'll also notice that, like, at first, the switch between kind and
糟糕之间的切换是相当，是相当，是相当罕见的，就像，在关系的最初几个月、几年里看到他们糟糕的一面，因为他们有点在测试界限。然而，慢慢地，随着他们适应某人并使某人习惯于他们的不良行为，那种糟糕的一面变得更加突出。他们知道，他们知道在开始时，好的和坏的行为之间的时间越长，就越难察觉，关系持续的时间越长，正在进行的生物和情感重连就越多，越多。越。某人越根深蒂固。这真是一个强有力的提醒，就像，人们可以在这些关系中待上几年。外部的每个人都可以像，这里出了问题，
awful is pretty, it's pretty, it's pretty rare, like, to see this terrible side of them in the first months, years of the relationship, because they're kind of testing the boundaries. Slowly, though, that terrible side becomes more prominent as they kind of adapt somebody and acclimate somebody to their bad behavior. They know, they know that in the beginning, the longer in between the good and bad behavior, the harder it is to detect, the longer the relationship continues, the more bio and emotional rewiring is being done, the more. The more. more entrenched somebody is. It is just such a powerful reminder that, like, people can be in these relationships for years. Everybody from the outside can be like, something is wrong here,
而它不会出现在他们的情感雷达上，因为它本质上是，我不喜欢使用像洗脑或斯德哥尔摩综合症这样的术语，但它是那种形式。它就像青蛙被放入沸水锅的经典类比。如果水已经在沸腾，如果某人把你扔进了一段虐待关系中，你会立即跳出来。但如果水在你周围慢慢煮沸，你不会注意到它。而在青蛙的情况下，就像，它们最终在逃脱之前就死了，因为水变得越来越热，直到它们甚至没有意识到。在这里不要搞错。
and it will not show up on their emotional radar, because it is essentially, I don't like to use terms like brainwashing or Stockholm syndrome, but it is a form of that. It's like that classic analogy of a frog being put into a pot of boiling water. If the water is already boiling, if something somebody dropped you into an abusive relationship, you would jump out immediately. But if the water slowly boils around you, you don't notice it. And in the case with frogs, like, they end up dying before they can escape because they just gets hotter and hotter and hotter until they don't even realize. Do not be mistaken here.
操纵性的人，他们知道如何瞄准这些成瘾、适应的杠杆，以及一切来让你上瘾。好的，我们要，我们要在这里休息一下，然后我真的想带你们过一遍这个清单，比如，这是创伤纽带吗？不是吗？以及事情真的变得更糟的一些迹象是什么？留下来。我们休息后马上回来。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性。健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家交谈，以及更多人，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。
Manipulative people, they know how to target these levers of addiction, of acclamation, of just everything to keep you hooked. Okay, we are going to, we're going to take a short break here and then I really want to take us through this list of like, is it a trauma bond? Is it not? And what are some signs that things are really taking a turn for the worst? Stick around. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到害怕的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会平静下来。但在另一边，一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在I-Hart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《TWO percent》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will calm out. but on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上也有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。真的吗？
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西，而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候我们已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对。那是两个不同的信任水平。我希望你真的成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》上。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾。
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·莱斯比安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻
Grega lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County
因为劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹。乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新赛季
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never messes. with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season
的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎不在乎。所以她们决定采取行动。她们自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我们已经谈过了什么是创伤纽带。我提到，你知道，有很多概念蔓延。很多人用这个词来指代不同的事情。那么我们怎么能真正知道呢？最大的迹象是什么？
of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. We've talked about what a trauma bond is. And I mentioned, you know, there's a lot of concept creep. A lot of people using this for different things. So how can we really know? What's like the biggest sign that this is going on?
我认为至关重要的是，要记住的一件大事是，所有的关系都会有某种程度的情感披露。就像，废话，人们会分享他们的秘密。人们希望会谈论他们的童年创伤。人们希望会谈论他们生活中正在发生的真正困难的事情。他们分享这些并不是一个迹象，表明，就像，他们正在利用他们的脆弱来操纵你。就像，这只是真诚的脆弱。
I think crucially, like the big thing to remember is that all relationships are going to have some level of emotional disclosure. Like, duh, people are going to share their secrets. People are hopefully going to talk about their childhood trauma. People are hopefully going to talk about the really hard stuff that is going on in their life. Them sharing that is not a sign that, like, they're using their vulnerability to manipulate you. Like, it's just genuine vulnerability.
所以我不想让你在关系的早期阶段，或者坐在这里想，嘿，就像，那个家伙刚刚告诉我他妈妈对他有多糟糕，或者，那个家伙刚刚告诉我他的前任以及她有多糟糕。他是在试图，就像，把他的钩子钩在我身上吗？不。在健康的关系中，有相互分享。有相互理解。对某些事情有同情心，对另一些事情有共情，对两个人的事情都是如此。
So I don't want you to be in maybe the early days of a relationship or sitting here thinking, hey, like, that guy just told me about how his mom was really awful to him, or like, that guy just told me about his ex and how terrible she was. Is he trying to, like, get his hooks in me? No. In healthy relationships, there is mutual sharing. There is mutual understanding. There is sympathy for some things, empathy for others, for both people's things.
从来没有指责。有时会很困难，但有。从来没有指责。而且你总是知道你们站在同一边，对吧？你总是知道，就像，这个人不认为这是我的错，对吧？在创伤纽带中，你被弄得感觉像是侵略者。你被弄得感觉你是触发别人情绪、行为和坏习惯的责任人。你是他们出轨的原因，或者他们的创伤是他们出轨的原因，或者做了什么可怕的事情，或者对你很糟糕，或者转变了。所以突然间你就像，我不知道谁是受害者，谁是恶棍。我想我是受害者。我想我是受害者。
There is never blame. And it will be hard at times, but there is. never blame. And you always know you are on the same side, right? You always know, like, this person doesn't think this is my fault, right? In a trauma bond, you are made to feel like the aggressor. You are made to feel like you were responsible for triggering someone else's emotions and their behavior and their bad habits. You're the reason they cheated or their trauma is the reason they cheated or did something terrible or were awful to you or switched. So suddenly you're like, I don't know who's the victim and who's the villain. I think I'm the victim. I think I'm the victim.
我想我正在经历一段困难时期，但他们把一切都搞得太混乱了。所以这些是创伤纽带的五个关键迹象。除了我们谈到的那种亲密和强化、起伏之外，还有一个明显的蜜月期，你可以回忆并回顾，它正在慢慢变成噩梦期。第二，最初想要帮助这个人的奇怪欲望。还有一种感觉，你应该能够管理他们的行为，也许他们的行为是合理的，可以辩护，可以最小化，因为那不是
I think I'm having a hard time, but they've made everything so confusing. So these are the five key signs of a trauma bond. Other than that, intimate and reinforcement, hires and lawyers we spoke about, there is a distinct honeymoon period that you can recollect and you can look back on that is slowly turning into a nightmare period. Number two, the strange desire to initially want to help this person. There's this sense as well that you should be able to manage their behavior and that maybe their behavior is justified, it can be defended, it can be minimized because it's not
他们，是他们的伤害，是他们的痛苦。就像你应该能够和他们一起解决这个问题。你不是一个坏人。你不会抛弃一个有创伤的人。最终，他们的痛苦似乎确实比他们自己更让你受伤，但你真的很关心，你只是试图善良。有过度警觉。最终，你会达到一种状态，就像，我不知道什么是正确的说法。我不想让他们生气。我不想让他们对我发火。所以有一种持续的、正在进行中的压力反应。你重读每一条信息，你重新考虑你说的每一句话。即使你想为他们做的好的事情，你也会想，这怎么能以最糟糕的方式被解读？因为你知道他们的思想和行为
them, it's their hurt, it's their pain. Like you should be able to work through this with them. You're not a bad person. You're not going to abandon somebody who has trauma. Eventually, it does also seem like their pain seems to hurt you more than them, but you really care and you're just trying to be kind. There's hypervigilance. Eventually, you will get to the stage of being like, I don't know what is the right thing to say. I don't want to make them angry. I don't want to make them mad at me. So there is this lingering ongoing stress response. You reread every message, you reconsider everything you say. Even nice things that you want to do for them, you're like, how can this be interpreted in the worst possible way? Because you know their mind and their behavior
会走向那个方向。有与支持系统以及与你自己的隔离。你曾经是一个支持系统。他们会找到方法让你脱离那些他们知道会打断正在发生的事情的人。也许通过要求你很快和他们住在一起，很快要求你所有的时间，很快要求你搬到别的州，告诉你，就像，他们不喜欢你的朋友，他们不喜欢你那个朋友，他们嫉妒，他们认为他们对你不好，你应该把所有时间都花在他们身上。他们也让你很难离开。如果你曾经坐在这段关系中想，我实际上只是非常不快乐。
is going to go to that. There is isolation from support systems and from yourself as well. You was a support system. They will find ways to detach you from people who they know are going to interrupt what's happening. Perhaps by asking you to move in with them really quickly, demanding all your time really quickly, asking you to move states really quickly, telling you that, like, they don't like your friends, they don't like that guy that you're friends with, they're jealous, they don't think they're good for you, you should spend all your time with them. They also make it hard for you to leave. if you have ever sat in this relationship and thought, I'm actually just deeply unhappy.
我不喜欢在这种关系中我是谁。这不是我想与之在一起的人。但在情感上，你就像，离开并不是一个真正的选择。就像，我不能离开。我的一部分不想，但我真的知道我应该。这是一个创伤纽带的重大迹象。在我的研究过程中，我实际上从这本关于自恋虐待的书里发现了一个测试，我认为这真的很有帮助。
I don't like who I am in this kind of relationship. This is not the person I want to be with. But emotionally, you're like, leaving isn't really an option, though. Like, I can't leave. Part of me doesn't want to, but I really know I should. That is a big sign of a trauma bond. During my research, I actually came across a test from this book on narcissistic abuse that I think is really helpful.
我不喜欢在这种关系中的自己。这不是我想成为的那种人。但在情感上，你会觉得离开并不是一个选择。就像，我无法离开。我内心的一部分不想离开，但我确实知道我应该离开。这是创伤联结的一个重要迹象。在研究过程中，我偶然发现了一本关于自恋虐待的书中的一个测试，我觉得非常有帮助。
And the author, her name is Vanessa, she basically devised this test to help people gain that clarity. That situation I was just talking about where it's like, I feel one thing, I think the other, this test like helps cut through that chaos and just be like, no definitively, like this is a bad situation. So you can kind of return to this, but I think this set of questions is really useful. First up, would you want your friends, family, sister, brother to be in this relationship? Would you want them to trade places with you? Yes or no? B, does your situation look toxic when you visualize somebody else in this same particular?
作者凡妮莎设计了这个测试，旨在帮助人们获得清晰的认知。正如我刚才提到的，当你感到一种情绪，却又在思考另一种想法时，这个测试能帮你理清混乱，明确地告诉你：这确实是一种糟糕的处境。你可以反复参考这些问题，我认为这套问题非常有用。首先，你愿意让你的朋友、家人、姐妹或兄弟处于这段关系中吗？你愿意让他们和你互换位置吗？是还是否？其次，当你想象别人处于同样的境地时，这段关系看起来是否显得有毒？
Maybe a celebrity, maybe a like a sibling or a friend. C. Do you frequently find yourself thinking or having to explain to others that like they just simply don't understand your relationship. Do you frequently have to justify the other person's behavior? You kind of have to pitch or like sell parts of this person to others. Do you know it is best to leave again, but you simply cannot? Do you feel like there is an invisible force keeping you to this person? And finally, do you feel confused, afraid, scared when you are apart from them? If your answer to any of these things just gets you thinking, some of these aren't like yes or no,
也许是某个名人，也许是你的兄弟姐妹或朋友。第三，你是否经常发现自己在思考，或者不得不向别人解释说，他们根本不理解你的这段关系？你是否经常需要为对方的行为辩解？你是否不得不向别人推销或美化这个人的某些方面？你知道最好离开，但就是做不到吗？你是否觉得有一种无形的力量把你和这个人绑在一起？最后，当你和他们分开时，你是否感到困惑、恐惧或害怕？如果你的回答让这些问题引发了你的思考，即使有些问题不是简单的“是”或“否”，
but if they just get you thinking, I think it might be worth just sitting with this for a while and being like, huh, how much of their behavior is actually not okay? How much of an emotional haze are they creating around our relationship? relationship to keep me hooked, even though they're treating me really, really badly. Let's talk about why, and this is like the natural next step, why are these bonds so hard to break, though? Like, what is the magnetism? I think this question, again, comes up all the time. Like, why don't you just leave? This guy, this girl, this person is awful to you. Think what people don't understand is like what they're really asking. Like how psychologically
但只要它们能让你开始思考，我认为就值得花点时间静下心来问问自己：他们的行为中有多少其实是不正常的？他们为了让我离不开，在我们的关系中制造了多少情感迷雾，尽管他们对我非常非常糟糕？让我们谈谈原因，这是顺理成章的下一步：为什么这些纽带如此难以打破？这种磁力到底是什么？我认为这个问题一直被反复提及。比如，为什么你不直接离开？这个人对你这么差。我认为人们不理解的是他们真正问的是什么。比如，像这样的处境在心理上是多么令人
imprisoning a situation like this is, especially if you are a kind, sensitive, empathetic If you are somebody who truly wants to do their best by everybody, you may see this person is genuinely just needing you and fixable, no matter how much holding onto them hurts and burns you. Like, you still feel like it's your job to make them better. There's also the fact that, like, your entire identity can become this person. Financially, yeah, sure, physically, yes. Mentally, 100%. They are your weekends.
囚禁，特别是如果你是一个善良、敏感、富有同情心的人。如果你是一个真心想对每个人都尽善尽美的人，你可能会觉得这个人只是真的需要你，而且是可以被改变的，无论坚持这段关系让你多么痛苦和煎熬。你仍然觉得让对方变好是你的责任。还有一个事实是，你的整个身份可能已经变成了这个人。经济上，是的；身体上，是的；精神上，百分之百。他们占据了你的周末。
They are your evenings. They are your thoughts. are what you choose to wear, what you choose to talk about, what you think will impress them, what you say to avoid a fight. Again, just to nail this point home, they are your safety. They control the danger. They are what, they bring danger and sadness and harm and cruelty into your life. They are also the one who can take it away.
他们占据了你的夜晚。他们占据了你的思绪。他们决定了你的穿着、你的谈话内容、你认为能打动他们的事，以及你为了避免争吵而说的话。再说一次，为了强调这一点，他们是你的安全感来源。他们控制着危险。他们是那个把危险、悲伤、伤害和残忍带入你生活的人。但他们也是唯一能消除这些的人。
So this means they control the negative. They also control the positive. They control the highs. And they can position themselves as well as the safe haven from other. external disappointing things in life. So you begin to like orbit them because that's the only way that you feel secure is if you're on their good side. Experts have actually pinpointed like a seven stage cycle of trauma bonds to explain like how deeply entrenched you become and what makes them so hard to break and walk away from. We already know like that first stage of like love bombing,
所以这意味着他们控制着负面因素，也控制着正面因素。他们控制着情绪的高潮。他们还可以将自己定位为避风港，让你躲避生活中其他令人失望的外部事物。于是你开始围绕他们旋转，因为你觉得只有在他们身边，你才有安全感。专家们实际上已经确定了创伤纽带的七个阶段循环，以解释你陷入得有多深，以及为什么它们如此难以打破和摆脱。我们已经知道了第一阶段，即“爱情轰炸”、
indoctrination, vulnerability. The second stage is like, again, when they start to test things out, so they start to just be like, can I get away with this? Can I not get away with this? What is this person going to do? It's at this point that if somebody kind of detects them or if somebody externally detects them and really like says something, they'll often like abandon the relationship
灌输和脆弱。第二个阶段是，当他们开始试探底线时，他们会想：“我这样做能逃脱惩罚吗？我不能这样做吗？这个人会怎么做？”在这一点上，如果有人识破了他们，或者外部有人识破了他们并指出来，他们通常会放弃这段关系，
or they'll often be like, they'll switch it up and be like, oh, I just, I don't want commitment. And like, oh, you're this person that like, I'm not ready for this relationship because they kind of can sense like, oh, there's a few maybe other guardrails. But if like some of them are really sneaky, like if they just happen to get away with it or if they've waited longer and longer to get away with it, sometimes it's just like very difficult to recognize. So there is this period after the lung bombing of like settling at times. And then these like short little sprinkles of like something's kind of happening behind. the scenes, like something's not going right. Then comes like the more intense stuff. And it's not
或者他们会改变策略，说：“哦，我只是不想承诺。”或者“你就是这样的人，我还没准备好进入这段关系”，因为他们能感觉到周围可能有一些防线。但如果有些人真的很狡猾，比如他们侥幸逃脱了，或者他们等待了更久才露出马脚，有时就很难察觉。所以在“爱情轰炸”之后，会有这样一个平稳期。然后是幕后发生的一些小动作，比如有些事情不太对劲。接着就是更激烈的阶段。这并不是
going to start out with like somebody doing something terrible. Maybe it does. But it's only, it's mainly going to be like criticism and devaluation. It's often going to be like verbal. And it's often going to be things that like they can blame you for. Right. So they're basically, again, it's like this boiling water analogy. They're like, slow. bringing you in. Like, how can I make myself the victim here so that this person, you, feels like the villain and I can get this all twisted? This is also very critical because they start to get you to want to earn their approval or earn their forgiveness for things that you are not at fault for. They're really like, they will work hard at twisting reality to villainize you,
一开始就有人做极其可怕的事。也许有，但主要是批评和贬低。这通常是言语上的，而且往往是他们可以归咎于你的事情。对吧。所以他们基本上，再次使用“温水煮青蛙”的比喻，在慢慢地把你拉进去。他们会想：“我怎样才能让自己成为受害者，让你觉得你是那个恶人，从而把一切都扭曲？”这一点也非常关键，因为他们开始让你想要去赢得他们的认可，或者为那些你根本没有错的事情去寻求他们的原谅。他们真的会努力扭曲现实来把你妖魔化，
to paint you as the problem. So you kind of enter this dance where like you feel blamed, you feel like you have to apologize, you feel like if they were to walk away from the relationship, it would be your fault. All of this is like deeply manipulative. It is part of the trauma bond. Then we get to the stage of like upping the ante.
把你描绘成问题的根源。于是你进入了一种舞蹈，你感到被指责，你觉得必须道歉，你觉得如果他们离开这段关系，那将是你的错。所有这些都是极具操纵性的。这是创伤纽带的一部分。然后我们进入了“加码”阶段。
This is when we get into like the, there's full on gas sliding going on. You completely doubt yourself. You suddenly uncover maybe lies that are happening in the relationship. This is when you're really like, oh my God, maybe something is wrong, but I'm so in deep now. I'm so bonded to this person. I feel so much like agitation when I'm not around them. And I'm so dependent on them for emotional validation that like at this point I just have to get through this.
这就是我们进入全面“煤气灯效应”的时候。你完全怀疑自己。你突然发现关系中可能存在的谎言。这时你真的会想：“天哪，也许有什么不对劲，但我陷得太深了。我和这个人绑得太紧了。当我不和他们在一起时，我感到非常焦虑。我对他们的情感认可如此依赖，以至于在这一点上，我只能硬着头皮走下去。”
And there is this continued illusion of another side that came at the beginning. There's this continued illusion of like things are going to get better. I think after a while when you realize this isn't going to happen and this is what recently. search us talk about, there is resignation. Essentially, your emotions and your body and your mind is like, if we're going to stay in this relationship, like, we should just switch off. Like, we want to be with this person. I care about this person. Maybe there are just parts of this that like we just can't engage in. So there is definitely a point that comes about where it's not that you just don't care anymore, but you're kind of just like, okay, this is just how it is. Like, I'm just going to make myself small.
而且，最初的那种“另一面”的幻觉依然存在。那种“事情会好转”的幻觉依然存在。我认为过了一段时间，当你意识到这不会发生时，正如最近的研究所谈到的，就会出现“顺从”。本质上，你的情绪、身体和思想会觉得：“如果我们非要留在这段关系里，那我们最好关掉感官。我们想和这个人在一起。我在乎这个人。也许有些部分我们只是无法参与。”所以肯定会有一个点，不是说你不在乎了，而是你只是觉得：“好吧，事情就是这样。我只是要让自己变得卑微。”
I'm just going to try and be good. And stage six swiftly follows the loss of self. After so many months of this manipulation, you lose sight of who you are as a person. You are what they want you to be. You are not you. You are what is required to make them stay in your life and to make them happy. All these things. What brings you joy?
“我只是要努力表现得好一点。”第六阶段紧随其后，即“自我丧失”。经过几个月的这种操纵，你失去了对自我的认知。你变成了他们想要你成为的样子。你不再是你自己。你变成了为了让他们留在你生活中、让他们快乐所必需的那个人。所有这些事情。什么能给你带来快乐？
What makes you excited? Your plans for the future. Your hobbies, your friends. it would be very hard for you to say because this is when they get you to the point of like you are indoctrinated into this relationship leaving doesn't just mean giving up the relationship it means giving up your entire sense of self it often means giving up money it means giving up all this time it means complete emotional withdrawal at this stage as well like there may be options for you opportunities for somebody to be like I don't want to be here anymore I want to walk away
什么让你兴奋？你对未来的计划。你的爱好，你的朋友。你很难说出来，因为这是他们把你带到“被灌输进这段关系”的地步。离开不仅仅意味着放弃这段关系，它意味着放弃你整个自我意识。它通常意味着放弃金钱，意味着放弃所有这些时间，在这个阶段也意味着完全的情感撤离。就像可能有一些选择，有一些机会让别人对你说：“我不想再待在这里了，我想离开。”
friends may get involved, whatever. But often that's when the cycle starts again. They will like turn on the charm. They will give you all this evidence that they are changing just to recommit you to the relationship. People who are in trauma bonds talk about the fact that it's not just one cycle. It's not just that they've gone through the seven stages once. They've gone through the seven stages like 10, 11, 50 times all over again.
朋友可能会介入，等等。但通常这就是循环再次开始的时候。他们会施展魅力。他们会给你所有他们正在改变的证据，只是为了让你重新承诺这段关系。处于创伤纽带中的人谈到，这不仅仅是一个循环。他们经历的不仅仅是七个阶段一次。他们已经经历了十次、十一次、五十次这七个阶段，一切又重新开始。
Like somebody bringing you back in. so that you cannot leave. So if that is what's happening, if this is a slow master plan to make you molded to this person, to make you feel like they're everything and you cannot walk away, how do you walk away? This happens in many, many ways. Obviously, like some people, like, their abuser just never lets them, and they just are never able to. But I do think that there does come a point for the people who do walk away and the people
就像有人把你拉回来，让你无法离开。所以，如果这就是正在发生的事情，如果这是一个让你被塑造成这个人、让你觉得他们就是一切而你无法离开的缓慢计划，那你该如何离开呢？这可以通过许多许多方式发生。显然，有些人，他们的施虐者从不让他们离开，他们就永远无法离开。但我确实认为，对于那些确实离开的人，以及那些
who have the help to walk away where they're like, oh my God, this is not love. And some people describe it as an epiphany moment. Some people describe it as a rock bottom. Other people describe it as like this gradual realization of like, this is not what people fantasize about. Like when I was a child thinking about love, when I watched those beautiful romance movies when I was a kid, like this was not it. Who would want to be in this situation? I don't see anybody else in this situation or maybe you do, but like I don't want this. for my kids, I don't want this for my friends, like, I don't want this for myself. This is not how I want to be loved for the rest of my life. And I think choosing to leave requires acknowledging,
得到帮助而离开的人来说，确实会有一个时刻，他们会想：“天哪，这不是爱。”有些人将其描述为顿悟时刻。有些人将其描述为触底反弹。另一些人将其描述为一种逐渐的认识，即：“这不是人们幻想的那种爱。当我还是个孩子，想到爱情时，当我小时候看那些美丽的爱情电影时，这根本不是那样的。谁会想处于这种境地？我没看到别人处于这种境地，或者也许你看到了，但我不想这样。”为了我的孩子，为了我的朋友，我不想这样，我也不想为我自己这样。这不是我余生想要被爱的方式。我认为选择离开需要承认，
firstly, like, that this is going to be hard and mentally preparing for that first. It will be at times emotionally difficult always, but also physically taxing. This is something I rarely see people talk about. People who leave relationships like this, like I honestly believe they should entitled to sick leave. Like, their entire immune system has often become compromised from chronic stress. So there have been all these, like, doctor reports or studies talking about how when people finally walk away from these relationships, they actually develop, like, month-long sicknesses. They feel physically stricken down. They get aches, fatigue, just colds, pneumonia, things they've never gotten before because their body, like, stops running on cortisol and stress.
首先，这会很艰难，并为此做好心理准备。这在情感上总是很困难，而且在身体上也很累人。这是我很少看到人们谈论的事情。那些离开这种关系的人，我真心认为他们应该有权请病假。他们的整个免疫系统往往因为长期压力而受损。所以有各种各样的医生报告或研究谈到，当人们最终离开这些关系时，他们实际上会患上长达数月的疾病。他们感到身体被击垮了。他们会出现疼痛、疲劳、感冒、肺炎，这些他们以前从未得过的病，因为他们的身体停止了在皮质醇和压力下运行。
and suddenly like the body has no more reserves to fight off things that it's been holding back. I wish people talked about this more like your body sometimes does like feel physically burdened by leaving this relationship. So there needs to be an acknowledgement of that but also some grace around that that yes you're going to feel mentally shit. You're going to feel physically probably not great as well. That is all part of your body I think like cleansing itself of this relationship. This is still grief, right? There is still a loss here. Our body, grieves anything that we were familiar with. Anything that felt normal and comfortable, our loss of that, our lack of that, like our removal from that, does feel like pain because
突然间，身体没有更多的储备来抵御它一直压抑的东西。我希望人们能多谈谈这一点，因为你的身体有时确实会因为离开这段关系而感到沉重。所以需要对此有所承认，也要对自己宽容一点，是的，你在精神上会感觉很糟糕。你在身体上可能也感觉不太好。这都是你身体在净化这段关系的一部分。这仍然是悲伤，对吧？这里仍然存在一种损失。我们的身体会为任何我们熟悉的事物感到悲伤。任何曾经感觉正常和舒适的事物，我们失去了它，我们缺乏它，我们被从其中剥离出来，确实会感到痛苦，因为
it was still something that you relied upon, even if it was unreliable. This is not, this is, again, not a sign that you should go back to this person. It is simply your body emotionally detoxing from a bond that had you addicted. We also have to appreciate the huge emotional and psychological draw of trauma bonds is how good they made you feel. And those times are not discounted by the bad times. You still lived both times equally. Both states of being in that relationship were ones that you've experienced.
它仍然是你所依赖的东西，即使它是不可靠的。这并不是说你应该回到那个人身边。这仅仅是你的身体在从一个让你上瘾的纽带中进行情感排毒。我们还必须认识到，创伤纽带巨大的情感和心理吸引力在于他们让你感觉有多好。而那些美好的时光并不会因为糟糕的时光而打折扣。你同样真实地生活在两种时光中。在那段关系中的两种状态都是你经历过的。
Because the good times were contrasted with such powerful bad times, they do kind of feel more emotionally profound. That's why the first week, the first month after being like, I'm done with this, we're done, can actually be really confusing. And I feel like people need to prepare for that. Expect to not know how to feel. Expect to not necessarily feel the elation you anticipated. Expect to question whether this version of reality is one that you actually want.
因为美好的时光与如此强烈的糟糕时光形成了对比，它们确实在情感上感觉更深刻。这就是为什么在决定“我受够了，我们结束了”之后的第一周、第一个月，实际上可能会非常令人困惑。我觉得人们需要为此做好准备。预期到自己不知道该有什么感觉。预期到自己不一定会感到预期的那种欣喜若狂。预期到自己会质疑这种现实版本是否真的是你想要的。
It is. Trust me, you do want this version of reality. You've just got to get through this tiny period first. There's also this cognitive dissonance. Why do I feel so devastated yet so loyal? How could I hate them so much and still care about them? Why do I feel like I'm to blame and yet I didn't do anything wrong? This is just your brain trying to regain its perspective and trying to retell the story in a way that makes sense to you.
它是。相信我，你确实想要这个版本的现实。你只是需要先熬过这段短暂的时期。还有这种认知失调。为什么我感到如此崩溃却又如此忠诚？我怎么能如此恨他们却又依然在乎他们？为什么我觉得自己有错，但我并没有做错任何事？这只是你的大脑试图重新获得视角，并试图以一种对你有意义的方式重述这个故事。
After it's been dictated by somebody else for so, so very long. whatever comes up for you, whatever like emerges, guilt, shame, fear, anger, sadness, it is all just your mind suddenly coming up for air from this terrible situation and suddenly encountering all these emotions that have been suppressed and trying to make sense of them so that it can pursue closure, so that it can pursue emotional clarity, so that it can pursue emotional clarity, so that it can give this story some kind of ending. That shame, that guilt, that is not for you to bear.
在它被别人支配了那么久之后。无论你出现什么情绪，无论浮现出什么——内疚、羞耻、恐惧、愤怒、悲伤，这都只是你的思想突然从这种可怕的境地中浮出水面，突然遇到了所有这些被压抑的情绪，并试图理解它们，以便追求解脱，以便追求情感清晰，以便给这个故事一个结局。那种羞耻感、那种内疚感，那不是你应该承担的。
That is not your burden. It is purely your mind trying to find the appropriate emotional reaction and just drawing on anything it can from the past that maybe slightly felt similar. That is not the correct emotion. Guilt and shame, they will come up. You did nothing wrong. You are not to blame for their behavior.
那不是你的负担。这纯粹是你的大脑试图找到合适的情绪反应，并从过去可能感觉略微相似的任何事物中汲取灵感。那不是正确的情绪。内疚和羞耻，它们会出现。你没有做错任何事。你不应该为他们的行为负责。
this is just physical and emotional withdrawal. This is, again, you're just trying to make sense of it. They are probably not going through the same things that you're going through because they do not have a conscience. They are probably not struggling in the same way that you are. They are not sitting here contemplating, did I do anything bad? Did I do what was right?
这只是身体和情感上的戒断反应。这再次说明，你只是在试图理解它。他们可能没有经历和你一样的过程，因为他们没有良心。他们可能不像你那样挣扎。他们不会坐在这里思考：“我做了什么坏事吗？我做的是对的吗？”
Did I hurt this person? And that in itself is the sign that they were the one to blame in this relationship. Because the very fact that you are considering even that you have a role to play in this, or considering that you, you know, should feel some guilt, should feel sorry for them, should feel some shame, shows that you are a much better person than this individual, and shows that, again, you have a conscience, you have care. They do not have care. That is why they are not considering it in this perspective. That is why, and that is the clearest evidence that, like, they were the manipulator. They were the cruel person in this situation. I want to take another short break.
“我伤害这个人了吗？”而这本身就是他们在这段关系中应该负责的标志。因为你甚至在考虑自己是否在其中扮演了角色，或者考虑你是否（你知道）应该感到内疚、应该为他们感到抱歉、应该感到羞耻，这恰恰说明你是一个比这个人好得多的人，说明你依然有良心，你依然有爱。他们没有爱。这就是为什么他们不会从这个角度考虑问题。这就是为什么，这也是最明确的证据，证明他们是操纵者。他们是这段关系中残忍的那个人。我想再休息一下。
here. So we can just really focus again on how to trust, how to feel, how to love, how to heal after these relationships, especially if you are encountering it or enduring it in your 20s. So stay with us, go get a cup of tea. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental topics. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
在这里。这样我们就可以再次专注于如何在这些关系之后去信任、去感受、去爱、去治愈，特别是如果你在20多岁时遇到或忍受这种情况。所以请留下来，去喝杯茶。我们休息片刻后马上回来。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，以看透主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people
我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们
scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, IHeartRadio app.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring, inconsistency, in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。男人应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe》。
So we did an episode a couple of weeks ago around how to experience healthy love after toxic love that I would highly recommend if you resonate with any of the things that we're talking about today. but I thought, you know, as we wrap up this episode, I would just give you guys like a little bit of a bite-sized summary right here so that you just get like the key high line points for this journey and this like recovery that you're in. Recovering from a trauma bond is never not complex, but one of the best things that you can do that I've heard from so many people is to find as many objective witnesses as possible. And not witnesses in like a legal sense. sometimes that is equally necessary, but I mean witnesses in the emotional sense. People who you can be truly open about your relationship with now that it's done, people who can and people who will confirm for you again and again, like that's not love. That's not right.
所以我们在几周前做了一集关于如何在有毒的爱之后体验健康的爱的节目，如果你对我们今天谈论的任何事情有共鸣，我强烈推荐你听听。但我认为，在我们结束这一集时，我想给你们提供一个简短的总结，这样你们就能得到这段旅程和你们正在经历的康复过程的关键要点。从创伤纽带中恢复从来都不简单，但我从许多人那里听到的你能做的最好的事情之一，就是找到尽可能多的客观见证人。不是法律意义上的见证人，虽然有时那同样必要，但我指的是情感意义上的见证人。那些在你关系结束后，你可以真正敞开心扉谈论的人，那些能够并且愿意一次又一次向你确认“那不是爱，那是不对的”的人。
That person was bad. That was bad behavior. People do not do that. You need those kinds of emotional witnesses. I just finished reading Strangers by Bell Burden, which, I think is an amazing memoir if you are going through this right now. And in her memoir, she basically details how her husband of 20 years out of the blue commits this terrible betrayal against her and takes no accountability, but also then
那个人很糟糕。那是糟糕的行为。人们不会那样做。你需要那种情感见证人。我刚读完贝尔·伯登的《Strangers》，如果你现在正在经历这些，我认为这是一本很棒的回忆录。在她的回忆录中，她详细描述了她结婚20年的丈夫如何毫无征兆地对她做出这种可怕的背叛，不承担任何责任，而且随后
like abandons her. And like overnight abandons their family and their children as like, I don't want anything to do with this. And one of the most powerful things she talks about in this book is this moment when someone completely out of the situation, like outside of the situation who really doesn't know them very well, kind of tangentially is like, that is bad. Like, no, whatever you are thinking, he shouldn't have done that. All your emotions about this are completely correct. And she just talks about it as this relief, this catharsis of like, finally somebody outside of me and outside of us can tell
抛弃了她。一夜之间抛弃了他们的家庭和孩子，说：“我不想和这有任何关系。”她在书中谈到的最强大的事情之一是，当一个完全置身事外的人，一个不太了解他们、只是侧面了解的人说：“那很糟糕。不，无论你在想什么，他不应该那样做。你对此的所有情绪都是完全正确的。”她将其描述为一种解脱，一种宣泄，就像终于有人在我和我们之外能告诉我。
me. This is what our pain often needs. It needs a witness. It needs somebody who will interrupt that self-enforced gaslighting that sometimes lingers when somebody else is externally gaslit you for a while. We need somebody who's going to be like, that was wrong. I can objectively, I don't have any skin in the game here. That person was bad. A therapist is obviously the best case scenario here. If you have access to that or a counselor or a psychiatrist, anybody who is trauma-informed is incredible. But again, sometimes that's not accessible. Even just having friends, new systems of support, family members that you trust, who will re-centre you with their honesty and with their honesty about what they saw and what they know about love and why that situation wasn't love is extremely
这就是我们的痛苦通常所需要的。它需要一个见证人。它需要有人来打断那种有时会挥之不去的自我强加的煤气灯效应，当别人在外部对你进行了一段时间的煤气灯操纵后。我们需要有人能说：“那是错的。我可以客观地评价，我在这里没有任何利益相关。那个人很糟糕。”治疗师显然是这里最好的情况。如果你能接触到治疗师、咨询师或精神科医生，任何具有创伤知情的人都是不可思议的。但同样，有时那并不容易获得。即使只是有朋友、新的支持系统、你信任的家庭成员，他们会用诚实来让你重新找回重心，用他们对所见所闻的诚实，以及他们对爱的了解，以及为什么那种情况不是爱，这是极其
powerful, especially because so much of your social life and emotional life has been wound up in this other person. It's going to be so easy to feel like you should just retreat into your shell. Nobody wants to see your emotional wounds. I promise they do. I promise, like, people around you, especially after what you've been through, they want the opportunity to love you, to heal you, to be there for you. That is a language of love that many people speak. They will provide that for you. They want to help you. Next, you need to restructure your beliefs. You might have deep-rooted fears now that people will abandon you. You are unworthy of love, that you did something wrong. Again, not true. So it is so important to take a step back and challenge that
强大的，特别是考虑到你的大部分社交生活和情感生活都与另一个人纠缠在一起。你会很容易觉得你应该退缩到自己的壳里。没人想看你的情感伤口。我保证他们想看。我保证，你周围的人，特别是在你经历了这一切之后，他们想要有机会去爱你、治愈你、支持你。那是许多人所说的爱的语言。他们会为你提供这些。他们想帮助你。接下来，你需要重构你的信念。你现在可能有根深蒂固的恐惧，认为人们会抛弃你。你认为自己不配得到爱，你认为自己做错了什么。再说一次，这不是真的。所以退后一步并挑战那种
negative self-talk. That is not your voice. That is their voice. That is the voice they implanted in your mind. I need you to ask yourself, like, is that really true? Is that really true? Your brain will always focus on the most negative thought you have about yourself or about the situation or about the future of love in your life because, you know, it is the one that scares you the most. And therefore, it feels like the most important thought to interrogate and to ruminate on and to question and to solve, or just to think about, because it's so scary you think, if that one is true, we've got to really sort that out. It's that age-old threat detection system we talk about on the podcast all the time.
负面自我对话是非常重要的。那不是你的声音。那是他们的声音。那是他们植入你脑海的声音。我需要你问自己：“那真的是真的吗？那真的是真的吗？”你的大脑总是会关注你对自己、对情况或对未来爱情生活中最负面的想法，因为你知道，那是让你最害怕的想法。因此，它感觉像是最需要审视、反思、质疑和解决，或者仅仅是思考的想法，因为它太可怕了，你会想：“如果那是真的，我们必须真正解决它。”这就是我们在播客中一直谈论的那个古老的威胁检测系统。
Our brain is constantly scanning, like, what is going to take us down? Let's deal with that first. Thing is, that threat detection system has probably, again, become hijacked by this other person, meaning your ability to dismiss your fears is harder because in the past, they made them come true for you. They knew what your fears were because they got you vulnerable and close. They made them come true.
我们的大脑在不断扫描：“什么会击垮我们？”让我们先处理那个。问题是，那个威胁检测系统可能再次被另一个人劫持了，这意味着你消除恐惧的能力变得更难了，因为在过去，他们让这些恐惧在你的生活中成真了。他们知道你的恐惧是什么，因为他们让你变得脆弱和亲近。他们让它们成真了。
So anything that gives you cognitive distance, anything that lets you be the judge and jury of your thoughts, not just the person who feels persecuted by them or who feels like these thoughts are dropped into your mind and you have to believe them, that is essential. This involves or might involve for you looking your thoughts, taking the false belief about,
所以任何能给你认知距离的东西，任何能让你成为自己思想的法官和陪审团的东西，而不是仅仅成为那个被它们迫害的人，或者觉得这些想法被丢进你的脑海里而你必须相信它们的人，这都是至关重要的。这涉及或可能涉及你审视自己的想法，采取关于
whatever you're thinking and providing all the evidence that it's not true, providing or generating five alternatives, making art from your thoughts, expressing them, like, in a creative way. Maybe it involves reprogramming through gratitude, through therapy. Whatever works for you, know those thoughts are not your own. Find a way, find a practice that lets you look at that thought it and kind of just examine it and not commit to it. And know that like your mind, as powerful as this other person probably was and definitely was in your life, you are equally as powerful in changing those false beliefs and changing those narratives that they have been planted in you.
无论你在想什么的错误信念，并提供所有它不是真的证据，提供或生成五个替代方案，从你的思想中创作艺术，以一种创造性的方式表达它们。也许它涉及通过感恩、通过治疗进行重编程。无论什么对你有用，要知道那些想法不是你自己的。找到一种方法，找到一种练习，让你审视那个想法，并仅仅是检查它，而不是承诺相信它。要知道，尽管另一个人在你的生活中可能非常强大，而且确实如此，但在改变那些错误的信念和改变他们植入你的叙事方面，你同样强大。
Because now you get access to your brain all the time. You are in charge. Think of it like weeding your internal garden of like the invasive weeds and vines that they have planted. Think about like visualize every time you take a negative thought, you identify it as a thought they have planted, you like pull it out from its roots and you throw it away. You are cleaning up the garden, your garden. Finally, and obviously there's a lot more to talk about, but for this episode, finally,
因为现在你可以随时访问你的大脑。你负责。把它想象成清理你内心花园中他们种下的入侵杂草和藤蔓。想象一下，每次你有一个负面想法，你将其识别为他们种下的想法，你就像从根部把它拔出来，然后把它扔掉。你在清理花园，你的花园。最后，显然还有很多要谈的，但对于这一集，最后，
the most important thing you can do after a relationship ends other than therapy, other than getting as much physical distance from that person as possible, is to work on creating a whole new universe of interests, people, weekend plans, evening rituals, creative rituals, practices, books, podcasts, favorite TV shows that they have no connection to. They will never get to touch it. They have never heard about those parts of yourself because the things that you only started doing after them. If this person was your whole world, it is time to create another planet of your personality that is just for yourself. They know. know nothing about this. This is all you. They will never, I just like cannot express anything that
在一段关系结束后，除了治疗，除了尽可能与那个人保持身体距离之外，你能做的最重要的事情就是致力于创造一个全新的兴趣、人、周末计划、晚间仪式、创造性仪式、练习、书籍、播客、最喜欢的电视节目的宇宙，他们与这些没有任何联系。他们永远无法触及它。他们从未听说过你性格的那些部分，因为那些是你只有在他们之后才开始做的事情。如果这个人是你的整个世界，是时候创造另一个属于你个性的星球，只为你自己。他们什么都不知道。这完全是你。他们永远不会，我只是无法表达任何
like you always wanted to do when you were with them and you never told them about and you never tried, now is your time to do this. Now is your time to put yourself at the center and to just completely plow and replant the garden. You have to forcefully dislodge them from your mind by pouring as much novelty, joy, newness as you can back into your life. I had a friend who left a relationship a couple years back now, who it was definitely a trauma bond. I think we always recognize it. She definitely does now. And she went and lived on a ranch for three months. Thankfully, she had the flexibility to do that. And when she ran into him, I can't remember when it was, like a year later. He was like asking her about all these things.
你和他们在一起时一直想做但从未告诉他们、从未尝试过的事情，现在是你做这些的时候了。现在是你把自己放在中心，彻底耕耘并重新种植花园的时候了。你必须通过向你的生活中注入尽可能多的新奇、快乐和新鲜感，强行将他们从你的脑海中驱逐出去。我有一个朋友几年前离开了一段关系，那绝对是一种创伤纽带。我想我们总是能认出来。她现在肯定认出来了。她去了一个牧场住了三个月。谢天谢地，她有灵活性去做这件事。当她一年后遇到他时，我不记得是什么时候了。他问她关于所有这些事情，
that like she was doing. And she just like had this realization of like, oh, you don't know anything about me anymore because I am not that person. I've completely recreated myself in my image, in the image of like, what is going to make me happy? And I think after these kinds of bonds, whether they lasted for two months, two years, 20 years, like that is the most powerful thing you can do, anything to separate your stories and to start essentially just like, yeah, rewriting, rewriting, I should say, your own.
她正在做的事情。她只是有了这样的认识：“哦，你对我一无所知了，因为我不是那个人。我已经完全按照我的形象，按照让我快乐的形象重塑了自己。”我认为在这些纽带之后，无论它们持续了两个月、两年、20年，这都是你能做的最强大的事情，任何能将你们的故事分开并开始本质上只是重写你自己的故事的事情。
So I think that is all we have time for. I could talk about this for so long. So if you have made it to the end of this episode, thank you. And I hope you're doing okay. And I hope that this has been helpful for whatever situation you are in. I just, it's so difficult. Whether you're trying to support a friend, whether you're trying to avoid this in your own life, whether you have been through this.
所以我认为这就是我们所有的时间了。我可以谈论这个很久。所以如果你已经听到了这一集的结尾，谢谢你。我希望你还好。我希望这对你所处的任何情况都有所帮助。我只是，这太难了。无论你是在试图支持一个朋友，无论你是在试图在自己的生活中避免这种情况，无论你是否经历过这些。
Like, this is one of the most awful, insidious kinds of relationships or bonds that somebody conform with another human. So you're incredibly brave. Hopefully now you are much more informed about what has gone on and what will, you know, what has gone on in your mind and in your body to make this kind of relationship so difficult to leave. And I'm just wishing you the best of luck. And I'm wishing you so much healing and self-love and just like confidence going forward.
这是一种最可怕、最阴险的关系或纽带，一个人可以与另一个人形成。所以你非常勇敢。希望现在你对已经发生的事情有了更多的了解，并且对你的思想和身体中发生了什么，使得这种关系如此难以离开有了更多的了解。我只是祝你好运。我祝愿你未来有更多的治愈、自爱和自信。
And I just know that you are going to, yeah, replant your garden with the most beautiful flowers and in the most beautiful way. And you're going to create an incredible life for yourself that this terrible, tiny, toxic person can never touch. So thank you so much for listening. Thank you, as always, to our researcher, Lucy Davidson. If you have made it this far and you were listening on Spotify, leave a little black heart in the comments below, just so I know that you are still listening. You can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast.
我知道你一定会以最美丽的方式，重新种下最美丽的花朵。你将为自己创造出令人难以置信的生活，而那个糟糕、渺小、有毒的人永远无法触及。非常感谢大家的收听。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森。如果你听到了这里，并且是在Spotify上收听的，请在下方的评论区留下一个黑色爱心，让我知道你还在听。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology Podcast。
You can leave a five-star review if you feel called to do so. You can follow us on Substack. There's so many things. Honestly, just check out the description of the episode and you can find all of our links to Netflix, to all that stuff, as well as, as I said, some further reading if this episode really resonated with you. But as always, as we wrap up, and especially with this episode, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
如果你愿意，可以留下五星好评。你也可以在Substack上关注我们。还有很多其他方式。老实说，看看这一集的简介，你就能找到我们所有的链接，包括Netflix以及其他相关内容，正如我所说，如果你对这一集很有共鸣，还可以阅读一些延伸资料。但一如既往，在节目结束时，特别是这一集，请注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。
We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
我们很快就会再见。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我解析了心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians,
1979年对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时光的。
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲生活？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA rating, app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much.
这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让一名女子怀上双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你两次伪造了这个特定的测试，非常……
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianciini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们组成了一支大军，揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·米安奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that. Trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是这么说。相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。